bonjour moi je suis calme linger
tremplin comment je suis fonctionnaire
hospitalier et je suis vice présidente
déléguée au développement durable et à
l'environnement
c'est dire voir des eaux regroupe du
coup si la hausse la rivière est l'antre
2 et ce sont des territoires qui sont
historiquement liés
dont l'identité créole et à la
le patrimoine naturel est vraiment à
mettre en avant je viens d eau je suis
encore deuxième d'origine donc oui oui
bien sûr je suis attaché à
village des eaux
au delà de ma délégation et mon souhait
en tout cas de continuer le travail qui
a été engagé en matière de développement
durable de protection de l'environnement
et de transition écologique je souhaite
avant tout que le département
s'inscrivent dans une démarche de
proximité parce que c'est une attente de
la population
effectivement le département et chef de
file en matière d'action sociale il ya
énormément dispositif à disposition des
de la population et il faut
impérativement qu'on soit plus efficace
donc ça c'était un projet en tout cas
qui me tient à coeur et un challenge en
tout cas que j'aimerais mettre en avant
c'est faire la promotion des mobilités
douces notamment la promotion du vélo
chez les jeunes et j'espère en tout cas
qu'on pourra mettre toutes les parties
prenantes la région les communes le
département autour de la table quand on
travaille vraiment ensemble à la
réalisation d'un véritable plan de
mobilité durable
[Musique]
on gère tout ce qui est agriculteur qui
est social tout ce qui est transition
écologique et
c'est un département tient une
collectivité qui est bien mais bien
évidemment important pour la population